un fuerte sismo de magnitud de 5.7
sacudió a la ciudad sureña de arnaiz
derrumbando más de 100 viviendas de
adobe incluidos edificios
gubernamentales el terremoto tuvo una
profundidad de 20 kilómetros con
epicentro a 102 kilómetros al este de
que está cerca de la frontera sur con
afganistán un helicóptero militar
transporta a las víctimas graves del
terremoto a la ciudad de kieta debido a
que el hospital de arnaiz ha quedado
completamente destruido algunos de los
heridos han sido trasladados por
carretera en ambulancias y los que están
gravemente heridos son llevados en
helicóptero los socorristas informaron
que los muertos eran en su mayoría
mujeres y niños mientras que las
autoridades confirmaron que cientos se
quedaron sin hogar el terremoto provocó
un corte de electricidad en la zona a
las 30 2m sentimos una sacudida muy
fuerte habíamos experimentado una
sacudida en 1997 pero esta fue más
fuerte mientras corríamos para salvar
nuestras vidas algunas personas se
cayeron en nuestras casas sufrieron
daños y también se perdieron vidas
quizás lo sepan fue un fuerte el
epicentro de uno de los terremotos más
mortíferos que golpearon el sur de asia
en 1935 un movimiento de magnitud de 7.7
dejó más de 30.000 muertos